EVENTS SCHEDULED WLY NOT JUST
FALSEHOODSUT
NKEDSP
STILLTOHEIN B DEFEAT JOEEN
HA THE MOST PART, MR. HDRAWN FR
VIEW.
THE CORONAVIRUS PANDEMIC, WHTINT
IS STILL DEVELOP PLAN
THI
SEVERALWNCO
ATTENDING CN EVENTSRODA
PRESIDENT TRUMPBESPERATELY, EIT
ISL MBHE BARRYINKNOWLEDGG
T
WON.
LET'S REITEWERS
IGHT OTHIS  NGED OUTGOING
IDENT.S, DEMOC AND
PU THERE IS N
CREDIBLE PATHON S IN ALL ORVEN E
CLEARLY, LEGMATELY
NOW, OFFLS THE WHITE THIS AND
IT PRIVATELY.
REPUBLICANS IN CONGRESS
ACKNOWLEDGE IT UESTIONS REMAIN
HOR.
BUT NONEF TANGE W HANUARY PRDE S
NOW, ONE P CNNRIBING THES
DEJEC
DEJECTED OVER HIS REJECTION BYI
UMP REMAINED BINNO
APHOTS OVER'T SPOKEN PUBLICLY S
LAST THURSDAY.D, HE H WAGED WHE
ON
WITHOUT EVIDENCE THE RACEDU A
PRIVATELY WONDE H GOING.SOURCEST
HA DEJECTED FOLLOWING HIS
LOSS, BUT HAS CONTINUED TO
POLITICALDVISERWERE DOUBTFUL T
CHALLENGL SUCCEED.
SEVERAL SAID IT'S ONLY A MATTER
OF TIME BEFORE TRUMPOWLOSS, BUT
TEASE THAT HEILL R IN  WHEN I E
EIGHT  YES, orter: AS TRUMP HOL
PARTY ARE
GI TO ADEFEAT.  YOUE CLOSE IN T
orter: KARL WHO
TRUMP CAMPAROTE OP-ED THAT TRUD
DO HIS PART T UNITE THENT ACE TN
AND LED LETRIEVAN
AT FIVGO SENATORS A
NOW CALLING FIDEN TOESIF
BRIES TRUMP
ADMINISTON >> IUR BFRIDAY STEP
AND PUSHEE
OCR.>> RepteSE SE WHO IS P UTP
SHOULD RECEIVE INTELLIGENCE
BRDAY.
>> HAS THE PRESIDENTSIDERED
THAT?
>> I H'T SPOKEN TO THEIDENT
THAT WOULD BE A QUESTION MORE TS
ITS L, THE WHITE
HOUSETI
FA F  ELECTION
NIGHIED T
CAS.LISCOREY
LEWANDOWSKI POSITIVE.
NOT THE PRESIDENT IN PERSON
SINCE LAST THURSDAY.
I CAN'T TELL YOU HOW RARE T IS
THISTE HOUSE, NOTTUALLY SEEN THE
AND US DILY DIDN'T MHERE'S NOT
LO ONINENES. N IS WHETHER OR
NO IS GOING TOTORAHA
HE HASN TELEGRAPNG ISMETHING HE
ESPECIALLY RETION TASNT TO
INALOU THAT
DECISION IS PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
ANRE ALONE.
JAKE, IHERE HAVE BEEN
MANY DISCUSSIOIDE THE
WHITE HOUSE WHETHER ONOSHOULD F
DEFENSE HAPPENINGNSE WING THIS
>> DIRECTORNTELLIGENCE
ARE SAYING TO TINFORM
CEETDS THUS SECURITYUT
OTHERS IN THATIN
HAVE OTHER PRIORITIES BESIDES
NATIONAL SECURITY. COLLINS, APP.
SOURS ARE TELLIESETTING FROMT T.
ME ISHE ?
ATHE S DREN ARGUIN WE'RE DIFFER
FROM  TRUMP AND HERBROTHERS, ER
GLORIABORGER WE'RE
TOLD BEH T SCEHALNGDENT AS O
HOW TO COME TORI
WITHIS LOSS IN U
ANSB
TRYINNAGA
THAT T ACCEPTED THA HE HA BUTHA
THE RECOUNT NOTEN.TON FOR FETIO
FUTURE.
THEY HAVE ATHAT PRESI TD SO
THEY WANT IT TBE -- T
TO FIG THE
ES FACE A HAVE EX CAT WITH DON H
THEY WANT TO THEY
N  OUTCOME OF
THEYTI IS HOPE
TO DO THAT. GETTI THESE
COMP HE IMPORTANT TO POINTVANKA
OFSSHA
PRESIDENT BECAUSE ALSO ONE
HY CHILDREN -- HIS ILD, I SHOU
SCENES, JAKE, HE HAS COME AR ID
. THOUGH WE'TGOING TO CONCEDE, Y
FOR THIS TO ALL
RE
SELLOWINHEPRES SAVE FND PRF-
LOGNITY,T'
LATE FOR THAT.
THAT SHIP HAS SAILED.
THE QUESTN HGNITY C H
DO YOU HAVE ANY S O WHY AHOW KAS
DIFFERENT FROR. AND RIGHT.OK T
ABLE TO CNGT? BEFORE ELECTION,
THE PRESIDENT S H
GOING TO ACCEPT THE RTS TSRIGGES
IN ALL O FEELSTON NEVER
ACLE
EL DOESN'T WANT T BIDEN.
AT OF THE
W
BUT FOR IVANKA TRUMP
KUSHNER,NG ABOUT THEIR FUTURES.
IVANKA K FUTURE IS VERY
MU  KHN A OF
WORK IN THEDL
PORTFOLIO DURIN H TIME ITHIS AD.
AND THEY DON'T T T UNDONE BY JFE
THE N CALLED FOR JOE
BI AND THE PRESIDENTSTILL AEP I.
BUTRE GOI BEHIND THE
SCMONG THE S
CHILDREN ANDRS, .
>> YOU CANVEAR THE
GHTHE ELECTION
THEINTR LNG TRANSIOPPATNT FOUR
TRUMP HAD VISITED OBAMA A T OFF.
SOATSNT
SOUR THIS UP AS SORT OFBUT WHIT
INTERFERENCE H.
AND,THEREFORE, THEYIKSHE NEVERT